I'm gonna also propose a question real
quick and I don't want to start a fight
or anything and I want to maybe I don't
want you to get angry with me I'm sick I
don't feel great okay
this is last night I was playing the new
DLC with my brother and some friends
yeah and my brother's girlfriend goes
okay that's enough and he got off Wow
because she probably drove an hour to go
see your brother and spend some time
with him cuz she's regardless of what
makes the reason is that's not gonna
keep him keep him that's that in itself
that kind of behavior is gonna make him
go [ __ ] this I think your brother's
girlfriend is she's amazing I think that
she's smart yeah I think that she's full
of character I think that she's so easy
to be around I understand that I love
her
exactly that's not what I'm saying what
I'm saying is is that you know the DLC
just dropped let the dude play did he
rage out after that no he was just like
okay he just kind of disappeared but
they don't see each other everyday like
you and I and she drives an hour to see
him so yeah if I go drive an hour to see
a dude and he just plops on his couch
and plays video games the whole night no
I'm out can I just say I'm gonna make it
I'm gonna do a reverse I need to get
some dick if I go drive an hour and I
don't know okay can I just say can I
just say this yeah okay is if let's say
you were kalila you love hula-hooping
okay you're addicted to it you love will
open you you grew up with it you watch
the videos right and one day you you
waited a year for new this new loom to
happen right it's like light you know I
mean it's got tech yeah you know more
circular yes circular you know min and
you just couldn't wait you googled you
read about it and it drops and you said
you know what Bobby I'm gonna be on this
hula-hoop for three days I bet go go get
it go do it because I know that you're
happy when you do it and I want to make
you happy
yeah but also can I say even if you live
that Alaska and I flew up there yeah
hula hoop your [ __ ] ass but that's
the point if I tell you hey Bobby I'm
gonna Huell
for three days yeah how about you don't
drive from LA no I want to see you nope
nope yeah yeah well I'm just telling you
how I am because I love you so much I
will I will you know what you go to a
different house I just want to be even
in your vicinity
I want your happiness to radiate through
the walls to like go into my [ __ ]
soul and I want to see your face light
up because you're so [ __ ] happy and
you could do it for a year everyday for
a year and if I didn't see you for
everything for you I would be bummed
because I haven't seen you but you know
what as long as you're happy I'm happy
and that's not what you did I don't
think it is right for us to ever discuss
anything relationship-wise with your
brother that's his private life and you
should never we dis she's gonna be upset
that we even talked about this this is a
who cares that's none of your business
what they do do together or how they
deal with it though it doesn't affect
you the only reason it affects you is
because he's been your toy your whole
life and now your playmate is playing
with some good
now it's ringing - Ricki Lake it's
turning into Wrigley it got no reference
I'm bummed because I'm standing in a
[ __ ] with aliens surrounding me on
the Cosmodrome right Steve Steve yeah
pop no you're not there oh by Bruce Lee
cuddling with a girl that you're like in
bummed and angry yeah oh no that's what
he abandoned his brother yeah in war
that's why I'm mad okay mothers in arms
I see Steve people always write some
[ __ ] and they always make him aware that
we had a discussion and it's not fair -
well I want him to know that yeah
[ __ ] cause some drama and a fight
with him watch it won't what's wrong no
I won't
that's his relationship let him handle
it sees fit
oh well not you know she's cool I want
it to work okay but she likes the red
house painters how climate cooler can
she be for you that took your favorite
ban and she actually knows their song
I'm just telling her if she's listening
that that's not the way and it was hard
that's all in time okay and I apologize
I said like again you say I'm sick I'm
confrontational and I say things maybe
black people do camp you know I just ask
questions
[Music]